It's the end of the line for one of the icons of American junk food culture.
Hostess, the company behind Twinkies, HoHos, those shaggy pink snowball cupcakes,...
...and Wonderbread has suspended bakery operations at its factories and plans to go out of business.
The company filed for Chapter 11 Protection in January...
...and recently warned its 18,500 employees...
...it would end business operations and sell off its assets...
...if workers refused to end the strike that began last week.
Thousands of members of the Bakery, Confectionery, Tobacco Workers, and Grain Millers International Union...
...began the strike after rejecting a contract that would have cut wages and benefits.
Founded in 1930, Hostess plans to sell its snack cake and bread brands to other vendors,...
...which means that we may not have seen the last of the Twinkie or the Ding Dong.